- [Instructor] So right here,
I have a container of water
that is open to the atmosphere.
It's standard atmospheric
pressure up here.
And let's just assume that
everything in our system,
the air and the water, the container,
everything is 21 degrees Celsius.
Now, our chamber is,
or our container of water is
divided into two chambers,
a left chamber and a right chamber,
which is divided by a
semipermeable membrane.
It's permeable only to the water,
but not to the solute in the water.
And on the left-hand
side, we have pure water.
So it's just molecules of H2O.
You could view that as distilled water.
While on the right-hand side,
we don't have pure water.
We have some sodium chloride
that has been dissolved in the water.
And we want to get a little
quantitative in this video,
so let's say it is 0.25
moles per liter or 0.25 molar
sodium chloride right over here.
Well, we know intuitively,
from our study of osmosis,
what is going to happen here.
Since our membrane is
only permeable to water
and the right side is
hypertonic relative to the left,
it has a higher concentration of solute,
we will have the water
going from left to right.
But what we're going to do in this video
is get a little bit more
quantitative in thinking about,
well, what is the potential of the water
to go from the left to the right?
And to do that, we're gonna
talk about something known as
water
potential,
which is denoted by the Greek letter psi.
Now, by convention, the water potential
of the pure distilled water
when it is in an open container
exposed to standard atmospheric pressure,
that is going to be,
so psi over here is going
to be equal to zero bars.
And as you can see
here, the units for psi,
for water potential, are the
same as the units for pressure.
Here, we're using bars,
but you could use PSI
or atmospheres or something else.
But what is going to
be the water potential
on the right-hand side?
Well, generally speaking,
you can break down
your water potential into
subcomponents, and the what,
the subcomponents that
we typically talk about,
but there are more, are the
component due to the solute
and the component due to pressure.
This'll often be known
as the solute potential
and the pressure potential.
Now, because this right chamber
is open to the atmosphere
and it's standard atmospheric pressure,
the pressure potential in this situation
is going to be equal to zero.
So our total water potential
on the right-hand side
is going to be the same thing
as our solute potential.
Now, to figure out our solute potential,
we will turn to a formula,
and I'll show you a formula
sheet right over here,
that's given by the College Board
when folks take the AP Biology Exam.
But we'll see that this formula
is actually quite intuitive
and related to the ideal gas law
that you first studied in chemistry.
It tells us that
our solute potential
is going to be equal to
negative i, and I'll talk
about what that is in a second,
times our molar concentration C
times our pressure constant R.
Now, they're calling it
the pressure constant
in this context, but
it's actually the same R
that we see in the ideal gas law,
times the temperature
in Kelvin, so times T.
So first, let's start with
i, so let me write this down.
This is going to be equal to,
it's all going to be negative
because all of these are
going to be positive values.
So i is known as the ionization constant.
And one way to think about it is,
for every molecule of solute,
how many molecules does
it disassociate into
when you put it into the water?
So if I take a molecule
of sodium chloride,
we know that when we put it into water,
it's going to disassociate
into sodium ions and chloride ions,
or into two ions for every one
molecule of sodium chloride.
So here, our ionization constant
is going to be equal to two.
Now, what's our molar concentration?
Well, we already know that.
Our molar concentration
is going to be 0.25 molar,
or we could write it as 0.25
moles per liter.
And then we're gonna multiply that
times our pressure constant,
which is the same as
the ideal gas constant.
And that is going to be,
they give it to us right over here, 0.0831
liter bars,
liter bars per mole
Kelvin.
And then we are going
to multiply that times
the temperature in Kelvin.
Now, what's that going to be?
Well, it's going to be our
temperature in Celsius plus 273.
So you add 21 plus 273,
you're gonna get 294 Kelvin.
And so this is going to
be approximately equal to,
we're going to have
this negative out front,
and if we look at our units,
let's see, we have moles
canceling with moles,
liters canceling with liters,
and then Kelvin canceling with Kelvin.
So our units are going to be
in bars, which makes sense
because that's what we
already talked about.
That's the units that
we're dealing with here.
And so let me get a calculator out.
See, we already have the negative.
So it's gonna be two times .25
times .0831
times 294
is equal to, and I'll just
round to one decimal place.
So 12.2, but I have that negative there,
so approximately negative 12.2 bars.
So our solute potential over
here is negative 12.2 bars,
or it's approximately equal to that.
And that's going to be equal
to our total water potential
because the pressure potential is zero.
So how do we interpret that?
Well, one way to think about it is
you can almost view it
as, since it's negative,
relative to the left-hand side,
that it would pull water
in, that the water,
if the membrane is only
permeable to the water,
is going to go from high
potential to low potential.
And that's exactly what we
thought would happen intuitively.
Now, another thing that
we could think about is,
well, how would we keep
the water from flowing?
Well, then we could add some
pressure potential right over here.
Maybe we could put a piston over here,
and we could apply some pressure
above and beyond the standard
atmospheric pressure.
Well, how much pressure
would we have to apply here
to kinda push down on that
water so that we don't have
a net inflow from the left to the right?
Well, imagine if this was 12.2,
12.2 bars that we were to apply up here.
Well, then all of a sudden,
this pressure potential wouldn't be zero.
It would be positive 12.2.
And then on the right,
we would have negative 12.2
bars of solute potential
plus positive 12.2 bars
of pressure potential.
And so that would add up to
be a zero water potential,
in which case, since the left
and the right-hand side would
have the same water potential,
you would not have a net flow
of water in either direction.
So as you can see, this
idea of water potential
allows us to think a
little bit more precisely
and a little bit more quantitatively
about these ideas of osmosis and tonicity.